[Music]
the federal government is suing the
state of California over its aggressive
stand against federal immigration law
Governor Jerry Brown in California calls
us an act of war and it is but who fired
the first shots is the question
California officials are trying to
undermine as we said the laws that
Congress passed Oakland Mayor Libby
Schaaf publicly warned of an impending
ice raid so that criminals could go into
hiding and escape federal agents
gubernatorial candidate Gavin Newsom the
former mayor of San Francisco says that
other local leaders should imitate her
Thomas Holman is acting director of ice
and he joins us tonight
miss director think your coming up
thanks Travis so when you have the
largest state in the country saying it's
illegal for anyone who lives in that
state private citizens to cooperate with
you a federal law enforcement agency
what does that do to the work you're
trying to do in the state of California
is a lot more difficult in the state of
California rather than taking custody of
a criminal and who's a public safety
threat inside this security and the
safety of a county jail right well we
don't have access to weapons now we are
forced to going to neighborhoods place
of employment to locate these public
safety threats on their turf where they
could have access to who knows what
weapons my biggest concern is one of my
agents will knock on the door someday
and he's not gonna go home that night
that's it very unfortunate because you
should have been old been able to
apprehend that person in the jail and
not be forced to going on hostert
arrested so this is making it more
dangerous for federal immigration agents
but if there's an irony here because the
state of California it's politicians are
claiming that you guys are going door to
door and rousting the innocent but
you're saying that their policies are
making you go Jordan clear the sanctuary
city policies are forcing our hand right
for decades we've had access to county
jails we can take you know someone's in
the country illegally and they're
sitting in the counties yet which means
they're not a choirboy locals and state
officials have not had made the decision
to lock these people up well in for
decades we once into jail identify MERS
that illegal elements and taken into
custody and remove them from the country
yeah moving from the community but
because they've limited our access to
the jails they don't share information
with us now we are forcing on
neighborhoods which when the governor
says he's protecting immigrant
communities and the mayor says she put
immigrant communities they're not
they're really some criminal aliens back
into the very communities they live in
they victimize so they're putting the
immigrant community to an increased
danger of crime and they put the
immigrant community and increased
arrests by ice because when we go to a
home to rest that target if we find
others there'll be a restitute they've
actually put them in a bad position and
I'll add this if they want you to
immigrant community and ask the
immigrant community where would you
rather have ice in a county jail or in
your neighborhood I guarantee they will
tell you the county jail how does it
make you feel to hear your agents
described in effect as bigots as a
domestic Gestapo by Democrats in
California it's an insult 20 20 thousand
American pages have worked for ice these
are men and women that get up every day
and strap a gun to their hip to defend
this nation they leave the safety
secured to their home every day to
protect your neighborhoods to protect
the community and and and they're
forcing the law that Congress enacted
they're doing their job as worn off so
it's an insult to many fine men and
women you don't make the laws Congress
does so what do you how do you respond
and Brian Fallon who's a former
spokesman for Hillary Clinton says the
Democrats ought to run on eliminating
ice you know if you look at the work I
said how many criminal aliens have we
removed from these communities how much
safer have we have we made these
communities you know these politicians
they need to talk to the victims of
alien crime talk to the parents that I
talked to that lost children
at the hands of criminal aliens that you
talk to California the California
sheriffs Association the governor's
sheriffs came out and support advice
they did a press release last night if I
can read just one sense of their press
release it shows Governor Brown is wrong
in this issue this is this has come from
his own sheriff's we oppose SB 54 the
bill is enacted still containing
significant liabilities which include
restricting our communication with
federal law enforcement but the release
of wanted undocumented criminals from
our jails including known gang members
and other serious offenders his own
sheriffs agree with what ice in deal
Jason it's shocking
Stroman thank you for coming on that was
great thank you for having good to see